on the mount for the angels and dylan
bundy making his second start as a halo
dylan bundy 27 years old out of tulsa
oklahoma
jp crawford leading off bouncing ball
through the hole beat the shift good
start for the mariners of jp crawford
here's left fielder tim lopes check
swing he went around
no hesitation from doug eddings a little
barking from the mariners dugout
one down so one out one on kyle lewis a
center fielder of down goes lewis back
to back strikeouts a little bit of a
quick pitch as well
two punch outs there's kyle sieger had a
nice game last night for seattle
kyle with 199 career home runs
kyle seeger with a walk and the mariners
have runners on it first
and second with two away that'll bring
up first baseman jose
marmaleo's two for 18 but scott service
likes the way that he's been swinging
the bat
eventually he's going to come up with
some big base hits and the pitch out of
the way
swinging a fly ball into right field and
deep going back
taylor ward and goodbye baseball jose
marmaleos welcome to the big leagues his
first
major league home run and the mariners
have taken a three-nothing lead
and what a thrill for jose meleos
marco gonzalez getting ready already for
his second start
of the season lead on battered david
fletcher steps in for the angels swung
on ground ball two hopper to short off
to his left crawford jp's throw to first
and it's in time to get fletcher and
there's one away
that'll bring up center fielder brian
goodwin swung on fly ball into left
field going back his lopes tim is there
to make the catch
so two outs for the angels here in the
bottom of the first inning that'll bring
up third baseman anthony
brendon swing and a miss at a fastball
up and in for strike three marco
gonzalez his first strikeout of the ball
game
a one two three bottom of the first
inning we had to the bottom half of the
second here in anaheim justin upton
leads it off strike three called and
that was
center cut and upton cannot get the bat
off his shoulder that is strikeout
number two for marco gonzalez and one
away for the angels
here is designated hitter shohei ohtani
swaying and a miss and a cutter away
strike three so back-to-back strikeouts
here in the second three strikeouts in a
row for marco gonzalez
marco gonzalez is the epitome of
pitching
good location good movement throws
strikes
swinging i miss and a cutter up and away
for strike three and that is strikeout
number four for marco gonzalez
one away for the angels here in the
bottom of the fourth another strikeout
for marco that's good when rolls went
softly
towards shed long junior tried to bare
head and there's the angel's first hit
i think he might have had a chance to
use the glove on that one because that's
one of those
swings there for goody that's tough to
get out of the batter's box
one on here's anthony rendon flung on
and it's popped up
right side down the right field line
over his ballok smith he's there now a
step to his right will make the catch
and there's two outs
for the halos here in the bottom of the
fourth inning strike three called on the
inside corner five strikeouts for marco
gonzalez he gets up and looking
at strike three and that'll end the
inning wow what a start for marco marco
gonzalez
really dealing tonight he's giving up
only one hit that has been it he has
five strikeouts along the way
line drive gets by him though yeah
that's uh that is poorly played by shed
long a break for the halos
that can hurt gonzales and the mariners
two out one on max stassi it's a fly
ball that's lifted down the right field
side tight to the line and that one
bangs off the foul pole down the right
side
that is going to be a home run for max
stassi
so the angels take advantage of the air
get the extra at-bat
3-2 seattle that'll be it for the
mariners opening day starter 94 pitches
phenomenal work for marco gonzalez in
his second start of 2020 runner now 90
feet away but there are
two outs so taylor ward is the better so
we're going to ground ball
right to j.p crawford mariner shortstop
has it throws and plenty of time to
first base
in and over hansel robles will work the
top half of the ninth inning to face
shedlong jr aaron is looking to add on
to that thin
one run lead swung on well hit ball deep
to right field this one is going
going goodbye baseball and it now gives
the mariners a four to two lead here in
the top of the ninth inning
one of your hottest hitters walking to
the plate and crawford winging a soft
looper into shallow left field that's
going to drop
in for a base hit a single by j.p
crawford drives in two more runs first
and third with one out for kyle lewis
swung on line drive into right field
that's going to drop in for a basic
two-run single for kyle lewis five runs
are in for the mariners
first and second for the angels ohtani
will
start over three tonight lifts a high
fly ball that's carrying deep out into
left center field it's out by the wall
and that ball is out of here it gets the
angels a little bit closer it's now
8-5 seattle the angels are down to their
final out swung on ground ball right
side
and right there is shed long he's got it
the throw to first
ball game is over the baron has won at a
final score of eight to five